cafetiers et restaurateurs ne décolère
pas donc face aux nouvelles mesures
restrictives entre ceux qui ont dû
fermer boutique et ceux qui doivent
baisser le rideau plutôt l inquiétude
grandit tout comme le cas de
contamination et pour parler de la
situation ces professionnels nous allons
retrouver nos deux invités et nous
sommes avec olivier marc et aux
restaurateurs patron du bistrot mais
zing à paris bon soir avec vous
christian saint-etienne économistes
bonsoir alors la colère des
restaurateurs christian saint-etienne ne
retombe pas parmi d'autres est ce que ce
sont les sacrifiés du coc vie
d'aujourd'hui
christian saint-etienne le gouvernement
comme vous le savez depuis mars
m'apparaît rita blement bien géré cette
crise
actuellement donc il ya un petit rebond
de l'activité du coc vide
je pense que le gouvernement est en mode
panique dans la mesure où on a laissé
pendant l'été un beau coup de deux
groupes se retrouver en famille ou dans
les boîtes de nuit ou dans les bars et
que même si les jeunes ne sont pas
malades ils ont été un gros vecteur de
deux déplacements de la maladie est
aujourd'hui le gouvernement était en
panique il décide de prendre des mesures
drastiques mais sans mesurer les
conséquences je pense que ça va être
l'objet du débat et je termine ma
réponse en vous disant qu'en fait le
gouvernement
outre la mauvaise gestion de la pandémie
par elle-même a énormément de
difficultés à être capable de balancer
les risques entre crise économique et
crise épidémique est ce qu'ils ne
mesurent pas la mauvaise façon dont on a
géré cette crise au printemps nous a
déjà coûté 750 mille emplois si on
devait avoir un nouveau plantage
septembre octobre novembre ça pourrait
nous coûter un demi million d'emplois
supplémentaires et je le termine en
disant que sur un million et demi de 1
million 250 mille un million et demi de
chômeurs de plus on peut avoir des
dizaines de milliers peut-être même des
centaines de milliers de faillite ce qui
peut provoquer beaucoup de concerts de
suicides et de dépressions donc
contrebalancer le risque économique et
le risque épidémique
ce n'est pas aussi simple il faut aussi
prendre en compte qu'une faillite
économique entraîne des conséquences
médicales colossal alors olivier mareuse
et où on entendait à l'instant christian
saint-etienne nous dire voilà cet été
bien il ya eu des rassemblements de
jeunes aujourd'hui on en paye les
conséquences notamment dans les bars ou
encore les restaurants
est ce que finalement les mesures aient
été suffisamment drastiques pour
aujourd'hui être au minefi d'amande
fermer ces mêmes lieux de barrez
restants aujourd'hui on a l'impression
nous d'être un peu les marqueurs de
l'action politique du gouvernement et
pas seulement aujourd'hui depuis le
début de la crise je pense que tous les
patrons de bar resto bistro responsables
ont pris les dispositions ont suivi les
consignes on fait en sorte que les une
distanciation qui existent que les gens
portent leurs masques à l'intérieur des
établissements on a tout fait pour
voilà après comme dans toutes les
professions il peut y avoir quelques cas
où cela n'a pas été respecté mais est ce
que pour quelques cas qui ne respectent
pas et l'état n'avait qu'un les
sanctionner doit-on pénaliser toute une
profession
c'est une vraie question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui parce que aujourd'hui nous
comme tout chef d'entreprise on a besoin
de visibilité et grosso modo depuis mars
nous n'avons aucune visibilité sur notre
avenir on va faire comment le faire
aujourd'hui on entre à précariser des
emplois c'est une période où
à la rentrée on prend des étudiants qui
viennent faire des contrats de 20 heures
aujourd'hui on ne les prend pas comment
vont ils faire pour payer leur loyer etc
c'est un renard vrai souci par rapport à
ça et nous on se demande comment vont
vivre nos entreprises demain mois alors
justement olivier marais tôt je me
tourne vers vous christian saint-etienne
l'exécutif a fait des annonces deux
annonces principal pour atténuer la
fronde prolongement du chômage partiel à
100%
jusqu'au 31 décembre et plafonds de
solidarité désormais fixé à dix mille
euros contre 1500 euros jusque là
christian saint-etienne est ce qu'on
peut sauver les meubles avec ces mesures
on peut sauver les meubles si l'afer
nature est extrêmement limitée dans le
temps
on a réduit la période de confinement
pour les individus deux semaines à une
semaine je pense que là si on annoncé
que la fermeture des bars étaient
limités à deux semaines avec une
indemnisation complète
ça permettrait de limiter la fronde
parce que vous avez raison il ya un
risque d' extrême dérapage sur le plan
politique c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné le gouvernement peut prendre peut
perdre le contrôle politique de la
situation
donc je pense que le gouvernement a
intérêt à dire on ferme deux semaines
les bars je n'ai personnellement je ne
vois pas pourquoi on ferme les
restaurants parce que si on applique de
manière extrêmement strictes les mesures
barrières dans les restaurants
normalement les gens sont protégées au
moins autant que dans les transports
publics dans un restaurant où on a un
mètre entre les tables vous êtes auto
autant protégé que quand vous êtes dans
le métro je prends sans arrêt et on est
à touche touche donc pour les bars
peut-être deux semaines max né les
restaurants je pense que il faut faire
une analyse extrêmement précises je suis
d'accord avec notre personne sur le fait
que le gouvernement doit être beaucoup
plus strict avec ceux qui ne respectent
pas les mesures barrières donc si on a
des restaurateurs qui s'engagent à
respecter très strictement des mesures
barrières je pense qu'il faut leur
laisser leur chance pour les bars c'est
plus compliqué
mais pour les restaurants je pense qu'il
faut les laisser ouverts olivier
marzotto donc ses principales
dispositions pour atténuer la fronde du
gouvernement tout à l'heure vous nous
disiez on n'a pas de visibilité avec ces
nouvelles dispositions
toujours pas de visibilité non plus
selon vous toujours pas de visibilité on
ne sait pas quelle échéance
on est pauvre on sait pas qui va fermer
qui ne va pas fermer est-ce qu'on va
fermer parce qu'on reste comme ça est ce
que c'est les bars jusqu'à 22h les
restaurants déjà c'était pas très claire
leur mesure
qu'est ce qu'ils appellent un restaurant
aujourd'hui est-ce que hambach qui sert
des planches et où les gens mangent
est ce que c'est un récent fait dans
tout ça il n'y a aucune clarté il ya un
vrai manque de clarté sur la
communication et il ya un autre point
qui est quand même essentiel c'est que
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas de quoi va
être fait demain mais véritablement pour
nous 1500 à 10000 euros est ce qu'on
perd 50 60 70 % du chiffre d'affaires
moi je suis une entreprise j'ai dix
salariés ils sont tous inquiets ils se
demandent comment on va payer les
salaires ils se demandent de quoi va
être fait demain
et comme tout chef d'entreprise je pense
qu'on est seul secteur où on nous dit
vous ouvrez vous fermez vous allez droit
de faire ceci vous aideront à faire cela
il n'y a pas un autre secteur où ça sera
accepté est donc c'est très compliqué
très compliqué christian saint-etienne
et scoop d'ores et déjà estimé un
certain nombre finalement
d'établissement qui ne pourront pas
rouvrir à l'issue de toutes ces mesures
et de ces fermetures
déjà on a une première estimation sous
réserve de confirmation un tiers des
feux des fleuristes en définitivement
fermé si vous prenez les restaurateurs
la crise du printemps si on rajoute des
fermetures maintenant on pourrait avoir
15 à 20 % des restaurateurs qui n'aurait
au bois pas je pense qu'olivier marzotto
a dit quelque chose d'important par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé à marseille
je pense que dans ce contexte il est
impératif notamment pour la région
parisienne qui est non seulement le
moteur économique de la france
on sait peu que
30% du pipe de la france est fait en
ile-de-france et en plus c'est la moitié
des recettes touristiques de france
donc pour l'île de france je pense qu'il
est impératif que le gouvernement ouvre
une concertation avec les professionnels
olivier marzotto disais à l'instant un
restaurant ok si tout le monde est assis
à une table mais si on sert des planches
comment ça fonctionne
donc il faut ouvrir une concertation
avec des règles extrêmement précises qui
permettent aux restaurateurs de
s'adapter si on considère qu
effectivement pour les bars c'est plus
compliqué même pour les bars il faut
donner une période très précises par
exemple dire on ferme les bars de
semaine on laisse les restaurants
ouverts mais avec des mesures
extrêmement précise et une concertation
qui permettent d'avoir des règles qui
sont claires pour tous les restaurateurs
voilà il faut un cadre précis et des
durée précise sinon les gens vont péter
les plombs parce que c'est leur vie
c'est tout ce qu'ils ont construit
pendant une vie qui se joue alors
justement les gens vont péter les plombs
là qu'on l'entend la colère des des
restaurateurs des gérants de bars un
appel à une action de brassards noirs à
d'ailleurs été lancé pour le vendredi 2
octobre à 11h45
c'est par le chef le chef philippe
etchebest
est-ce que vous alliez il participe et
olivier marais tôt oui bien sûr tout ce
qui aujourd'hui peut faire porter la
voix des restaurateurs et notre
profession est important je pense qu'il
ya un point qu'il est aussi très
important c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans la
communication du gouvernement
il n'y a aucun chiffre concret sur les
cas qui sont sortis à cause des bistrots
on a vraiment on a vraiment l'impression
d'être marqueur de l'action politique et
que aujourd'hui si les explications de
gouvernement sur les cas issus de notre
profession était chiffré clair précis il
n'aurait pas cette fronde
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que dès
qu'ils veulent faire quelque chose à un
moment il rompt dit on ferme quelque
chose à hébron fermé bistrot on ferme
les yeux les lieux de convivialité
mais la grande erreur nous on les
clients les
tous les jours c'est que aujourd'hui un
des principaux endroits de kloster c'est
les réunions familiales ou les réunions
amicales dans les appartements il faut
pas croire que si on ferme les gens vont
arrêter de vivre
ils vont se retrouver dans des
appartements sans aucune marier sans
aucune barrière sans aucun gestes
barrières sans protection etc
et je pense qu'on assistera à la
continuité d'une progression du cac au
vide voilà christian saint-etienne est
ce que vous vous rejoignez ce constat
d'olivier ma rhéto qui pointe un manque
de clarté du gouvernement dans ses
échanges avec les restaurateurs les
barmans il ya deux points de ce que
vient de dire olivier marais tôt sur
lequel je rejoins le premier c'est le
manque de concertation je les ai évoqué
précédemment
donc c'est extrêmement important qui est
des règles qui soient concertées avec
les professionnels met le deuxième point
sur lequel je le rejoins je lui ai dit
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire dans
des interviews
c'est effectivement la sphère
personnelle les allemands viennent
d'annoncer que selon les régions
département par département en allemagne
par lander ou par ville
il va y avoir des limites aux réunions
de la sphère personnelle c'est à dire
que ça n'a pas de sens de fermer les
bars et les restaurants si on permet aux
gens de s'assembler à 50 ou à 100 dans
des résidences dans des maisons de
campagne ou dans des salles de fête donc
dans la concertation qu'il faut ouvrir
avec les bars restaurants
il faut inclure la réflexion sur scorff
ont déjà lancé les allemands c'est à
dire les limites à mettre sur la sphère
personnelle
il faut une cohérence entre ce qui est
fait du côté des bars restaurants et ce
qu'on fait sur la sphère personnelle
sinon c'est incompréhensible pour tout
le monde alors olivier marzotto dans ce
contexte on voit le nombre de cas de
contamination qui augmente le nombre de
décès également qu'est ce que vous
proposez vous très concrètement
aujourd'hui au gouvernement
nous ce qu'on propose c'est déjà qu'ils
fassent est appliquée
les mesures qu'ils ont prises je pense
que notre profession si elle applique un
protocole qui a été négocié avec le
gouvernement peut pas l'oublier c'est
pas nous qui avons inventé le protocole
qui aujourd'hui est en tête dans les
bars et ce temps si on met déjà les
moyens pour faire appliquer et
sanctionner les contrevenants à ce
protocole on pourra continuer à faire
vivre nos entreprises sauvegarder les
emplois à créer une continuité dans la
convivialité aussi parce que les gens
ont besoin de ça dans cette période
extrêmement tendu tout le monde tout le
monde ont besoin de ça et on pourra tous
vivre ensemble en faisant attention à ne
pas propager ce ce qu vide
christian saint-etienne pour conclure
alors au delà de la conséquence directe
sur les propriétaires et et personnels
de bars et restaurants est ce que ces
fermetures ont un impact économique sur
d'autres secteurs
oui j'y pense et alain stands on veut il
faut que l'économie fonctionne sinon on
va creuser collectivement on vient de
voir que le confinement du printemps
nous a coûté 750 mille emplois et 200
milliards de dette publique en plus on a
une dette publique qui va être la fin de
l'année à 118 points de pib alors que
notch et quasiment le double de ce qui
est permis dans le traité de maastricht
et les règles européennes c'est à dire
60 points pipe
vous avez des restaurateurs qui après la
claque du printemps ont pris dans leurs
économies pour relancer leurs activités
si on leur balance une baffe à l'automne
je pense qu'on va perdre tout un secteur
d'activité qui est clé à la fois pour le
tourisme parce que les touristes qui
viennent à paris ou dans d'autres
régions de france ils viennent aussi
pour la convivialité qu'on trouve dans
les bars et les restaurants donc si vous
avez tout un segment de l'offre qui
disparaissent a réduit l'attractivité en
termes de tourisme
mais l'autre aspect c'est qu'on veut que
l'économie continue de fonctionner donc
il faut que les gens déjeunent à midi
c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure je
pense le contrôle des la profession des
bars restaurants mais je fais une
distinction entre bars et restos pour
moi c'est presque un service public les
instants
le restaurant notamment midi pour que
les champs travail donc si on ferme les
restaurants ça envoie un signal
extrêmement négatif et est même avec un
risque sanitaire supplémentaire parce
que si les gens ne peuvent pas manger
dans des restaurants dans lesquels on
appliquera strictement les règles
barrière qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
ils vont se faire des boîtes pour
déjeuner ils vont aller manger des
sandwichs et ils vont le manger au
bureau ils voient en elle mangeait dans
des salles de danse dans l'entreprise où
il ya un bar ils vont être collés les
uns aux autres donc en terme de règles
barrière c'est pire que d'aller au
restaurant donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
que le gouvernement pense à 3 à 3
simultanément à trois éléments
bien sûr la survie du secteur des
départs restaurant mais c'est également
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure il faut
qu'il y ait une cohérence entre les
règles imposées à ce secteur et ce qu'on
fait dans la sphère privée
on peut pas on peut pas dire enfermés
par restaurant et on laisse les gens se
réunira 200 dans une salle des fêtes
au petit jeu brigue et troisième élément
d'une concurrence conséquences d'une
fermeture des restaurants parce que
d'une certaine façon c'est un service
public
si on veut que l'économie continue on a
besoin que les travailleurs puissent se
restaurer merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci à vous
olivier marais tout je rappelle que vous
êtes restaurateur à patron du bistrot
mais zynga paris merci avoue christian
saint-etienne je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste